meet jonathan
he is an investigative journalist who
occasionally researches and publishes
news articles contrary to the
government's ideologies
on one such occasion he could not access
a global news website dealing with
uncensored information
it seemed his ip was blocked from
visiting the news website
with his ip blocked jonathan turned to a
popular proxy service that was able to
unblock the news website
thereby allowing an open internet to all
users
just like how your friend gives a proxy
attendance for you a proxy server serves
as a stand-in user to keep the real
client private
but what is a proxy let's understand
it's working by taking a look at how
jonathan was able to access geoblock
content without much hassle
a proxy server acts as a gateway or
intermediary server between a user and
its destination website
when jonathan wasn't able to access the
news website he connected his system to
a global proxy server
once connected the proxy server assigns
a new ip address to jonathan's system
an ip address of a different country
where the website is not censored
following this process whenever jonathan
visits that website the website
administrators see the new ip address
assigned via proxy server and sees no
reason to deny access to their account
once the proxy server is able to access
the website it's passed on to jonathan's
system via the same channel
regarding accessibility to proxy servers
you must first set it up on your
computer device or network
next check the steps required for your
computer or network as each operating
system has its setup procedures
in most cases however setup entails
using an automated configuration script
there are plenty of free proxy services
available on the internet
however the safety of such proxies is
rarely verified
most free proxies will provide an ip
address and a relevant port for
connection purposes
reputed proxy providers like smart proxy
and write data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection
this extra step acts as authentication
that verifies an existing subscription
on the proxy provider server
unlike free providers that are open to
all
when it comes to hiding ip addresses
many people consider a vpn to be the
primary solution
while that's true up to some extent
there are a few things proxies do
differently
in the case of vpns extra encryption is
also carried out to create a secure
tunnel between the user's device and a
vpn server
a vpn is usually much faster more secure
thanks to multiple layers of encryption
and has little to no downtime
proxies tend to be comparatively unsafe
with the service owners having the exact
ip address of the end user and having no
guarantees regarding down times and
reliability
if you want to know more about how vpns
work do watch how jude could have
protected her banking credentials using
vpns in our detailed video linked above
now let's take a small quiz to check how
much we have learned
what can a vpn connection provide that a
proxy service cannot
a new ip address
b
multiple layers of encryption
c access to geoblock content
d authentication credentials
think about it and leave your answers
below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
what about the benefits of a proxy
service though
besides allowing access to blocked
content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system they can also
filter content from third-party websites
allowing control over internet usage
in many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla internet
thanks to proper optimization on the
base proxy server
the element of privacy proxies provides
is highly lucrative to people looking to
hide their actual ip address from as
many prying eyes as possible
one can easily argue the benefits of
using vpns over proxies for added
security measures
however a few basic tasks don't warrant
maximum privacy for the user's side as
in other cases
for example many consumers worldwide
find proxy services more convenient
since all major operating systems
starting from windows to android allow
proxy configuration without the hassle
installing new applications as is in the
case of a vpn
in addition there are services online
that function as web proxies allowing
users to access blocked content without
any setup from their end
they can enter the target url and the
web proxy will route data from its
physical server
this level of freedom is hard to come by
in the case of vpns making proxies an
ideal solution for casual browsing we
hope you enjoyed this video if you did a
thumbs up would be really appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]
you